uh well joining me now is retired
everybody special Sean Bell um to react
to What Ben Wallace had to say earlier
Sean M what are the importance of his
comments he announced that Britain is
sending tanks to Ukraine he did that in
the House of Commons a few days ago he's
now there talking about long-term
planning what's the what's the overall
aim of what he's trying to do yeah
there's the headline stuff and then
there's what's going behind the scenes
isn't there Ben Willis a military base
in Estonia very strong statement let's
be in context the next to the U.S the UK
is one of the leading contributors of
military aid to to Ukraine uh Mr Wallace
pointed out reiterated that the
challenge of twos were now being sent to
um to Ukraine up to 14 of them but all
of this is actually designed to increase
pressure on European colleagues to match
this uh this uh support and actually in
breaking news
um literally in advance of the meeting
tomorrow 10 and 10 countries have
already announced a raft of military aid
um which it um it's like air defense
systems and extra training so be
interested to see what else gets
reported tomorrow more and that's the
moment but um Ben Wallace also
highlighted the need for a multi-year
strategy one of the things that Putin's
been doing is mobilizing the defense
industry and preparing his domestic
audience for the long term fully
expecting a West appetite this war will
diminish over time Ben Morris was very
clear in his firmness of resolve for the
long term here the challenge will be
turning those words into action what we
do know though is that the polls
recently conducted Today Show very
strong UK support for continuing the
military aid there's well over
two-thirds of the UK population uh voted
that either to maintain or increase the
level of sport for this for this war
um Ukraine of course welcomed the supply
of tanks from the UK but everybody's got
their eyes on Germany because they want
Germany's tanks and explain to us why
that is so important that Germany also
steps up and provides them yeah it's
been interesting a whole conversation
about tanks because Europe was very
happy to support um Ukraine when it was
on the defense but actually moving to
the offense and providing things like
tanks
risks being seen as escalatory and
that's put a little bit of concern in
some European Leader's mind president
zielinski has asked for at least 300
main battle tanks so whilst the
Challenger 2 14 of them is welcome it it
doesn't scratch the surface of what he
actually needs what he wants is um
Abraham's tank The American or leopard
twos there are two thousand of those in
service around the world with 13
different nations uh and even Poland has
already said it's ready to donate a
company's worth of these tanks but it
will only do that in concert with other
nations contributing as well now German
controls the export license for these so
no Nation can forward them on to Ukraine
without their sport that's why the U.S
defense secretary is meeting with his
German counterparts uh reports are
suggests that Germany will acquiesce if
the U.S puts their Abraham's tanks into
uh Ukraine but I suspect there's a lot
of politics behind the scenes here that
the US that who are by far the biggest
donors of money and military aid will
probably see this as a great opportunity
for Europe to step up tomorrow is the
big meeting over 50 Nations represented
at the military Air Base at Ramstein
president zelenski has been appealing
for help he did it at Davos but he's
also done it from Kiev today I need
tanks but I need them quickly ready for
spring offensive I think my military
reflection there's an evident need to
move from this rather reactive
fragmented approach to some sort of
long-term strategy because bluntly if
Ukraine loses this war that has huge
significance for Global Security